ah
[Música]
esta semana llegó a nueva delhi cerca de
la mitad de la ayuda que eeuu le enviará
a india una ayuda estimada en 100
millones de dólares que incluye 15
millones en máscaras en el 95 un millón
de dólares en exámenes de diagnóstico
rápido y 1100 cilindros de oxígeno
reutilizables pero expertos en salud
pública le están pidiendo al gobierno de
bailén que relaje las restricciones para
exportar el material necesario para
producir más vacunas en india y que
donde además a este país la cerca de 30
millones de dosis de la vacuna de
astrazéneca que tiene eeuu almacenadas
lo que resulta paradójico es que en
india está una de las empresas que más
vacunas produce en el mundo y que
produce precisamente la vacuna de
astrazéneca
[Música]
el presidente chino si se empina enviado
sus condolencias a indiana ofrecido toda
la ayuda que pueda necesitar y animado a
las compañías chinas a que cooperen con
el vecino asiático china enviado ya
ochocientos concentradores de oxígeno y
enviar a otros diez mil durante esta
semana aquí se subraya ese gesto en
contraste con el egoísmo estadounidense
en general y más en concreto con el veto
de joe biden a enviar a india los
ingredientes que necesita para fabricar
sus vacunas y que sólo fue levantado
recientemente y tras recibir muchas
presiones internacionales china-india
acumulan décadas de roces fronterizos
que el año pasado desembocaron en la
muerte de decenas de soldados de ambos
bandos y antes de que india quedara
devastada por la segunda ola habían
rivalizado con sus respectivas
diplomacias de las vacunas en atraer las
simpatías de países de la zona como ri
lanka o nepal los expertos esperan que
esta ayuda contribuya a rebajar las
tensiones
[Música]
bajo la premisa de que la lucha contra
la pandemia es una lucha común una lucha
global el gobierno alemán puso en marcha
lo que ha sido descrito como una misión
urgente de apoyo a india como parte de
esa misión el gobierno alemán ya envió a
principios de mes 120 ventiladores
además de un equipo de expertos
conformado por 13 personas que tienen la
labor de recibir una planta de
producción de oxígeno de instalarla en
el país y también de instruir al
personal sanitario indio en particular a
miembros de la cruz roja una decisión
adicional tomada por las autoridades
alemanas en particular para evitar
infecciones aquí en el país es la de
restringir vuelos provenientes de india
actualmente sólo pueden ingresar a
alemania provenientes de ese país
ciudadanos o residentes alemanes y
solamente bajo estrictas condiciones de
higiene
[Música]